IDC is dairy, but the Budwig diet of cottage cheese and flax oil is recommended. Do you suggest they stay away from that entirely or maybe do it once in a while?
So, if dairy is a driver of your cancer, if you talk to the people from Budwig, they'll say that adding flax oil to the cottage cheese and blending it up
changes the dairy and it no longer drives cancer.
But from a physiological standpoint, that makes no sense. You can cook dairy in a pasta. You can make dairy into cheese. You can make dairy into whatever you want.
But it's still going to have the same physiological effect on your body.
That's not going to change the dairy so that it won't be a gross driver. The most dairy is a growth driver or I should say dairy is a growth driver for most people's cancer.
If a person says, okay, well, I know dairy is a driver, but I do want to do Budwig and they're staying away from all other dairy, but they're doing Budwig.
That's it. That's just a call that you have to make. I mean, if you're really going to stay away from all dairy, you can't do Budwig.
But if you're going to make that call with your, let's say your cancer is in a state where it's growing and I've been dairy free for a period of time and now it's growing and I want to try the Budwig protocol, then I don't have any trouble with trying the Budwig protocol.
And if you're at a state where there isn't, there's very little growth and you're doing well and you're off dairy, I would be very hesitant to try the Budwig protocol.
I just got off the phone with somebody yesterday who was doing very, very well with their cancer and for some reason they got off of their diet because their husband was doing a carnivore type diet.
You had a carnivore type diet with dairy and he was eating a punch of dairy with meat and she started on that diet with him and she had a big flare.
But I think it was more a flare of dairy sensitivity issue because she was having all sorts of weird symptoms and I don't think we're tied to her cancer, but it can make a change that fast.
So it really depends on where the person's at with their cancer. So if your cancer is fairly stable at the moment and you're dairy free, I wouldn't go jump into the Budwig diet.
If your cancer was growing and you've been dairy free and you've been doing a lot of things and you want to give Budwig a shot that I, that I would say go forward give Budwig a shot.
That's up to you.
But you, but I would not I do not believe what the Budwig people say is that if you had a black seed to the to the cottage cheese it changes the physiological characteristics of dairy well there's no evidence of that.
I don't believe that, but I don't see a problem with somebody trying to.